that was like hustling since I was like
12. I knew I made it when
I got my my mom into a space where it
was better than they got themselves into
like it's a new house but they don't
have to work things like that now I feel
like that's the biggest thing I
accomplished
see the most expensive thing we spend is
time
this is why even the the biggest
punishment you can receive is not
she's gonna have Peaks and valleys so I
have things changed in your career at
that point and you feel like is it at
Ohio is it how low you don't can't even
I never wanted to be someone different
I wanted to be a better version of me
like to have not have the restraints
that I had
you know and when you come up with our
finances it seems like the biggest
restraint
and uh
it makes you make that Financial or
money focused and I feel like that's the
answer but they'll always be new
confusion or new situations that show up
I believe in depression
is a luxury
tough situations like still look at it
like I got to get up and do what I got
to do regardlessly I can't not
do what I got to do so I'll work
depressed or when I'm when I'm feeling
those feelings I say I just don't feel
good but I still do everything I'm
supposed to do for the day you know like
that just is not acceptable in in the
early stages so you look and you go if
you felt those feelings and you felt
like you were depressed for whatever
reasons you still got up and deal with
you anybody who have a long enough
career has peace and balance you know
and then with the upsides and the
downsides you you just work through it
so every time you in a position where
you feel like it's going down it's only
for it to go back up again a watch that
happen repeatedly it goes goes It goes
down then it goes up higher than it was
the last time it was up every single
time I think the only thing
raise people is their passion
right and
and when you become really passionate
about something you can work at it until
you're good enough to you on that top
level of performance so like if you see
sometimes people it may be some sort of
genetics involved with it but when you
see Fighters like you see Floyd
Mayweather Floyd Mayweather senior is
what inspired him and created that
passion and made him turn into what he
is and Kobe Bryant his dad was
professional was a ball player too you
got Vegas and Serene today dad helped
him out and you have people around you
that can help you get the right
information or help you do it the right
way early
that you can actually become good enough
to do it
you start to think about what Jack
genuinely after
and that's happiness
you know so I'll always pick a new goal
and move forward in different ways so
that
I think ambition is a tunnel that you
run through that doesn't it anyone who's
extremely focused is
is considered it could be considered
ruthless at points
because if they get in the way where I'm
trying to do what I'm doing I just knock
them out the way
well the most ruthless people or did you
run into are going to be people that are
just focused
and not necessarily taking your life
into the celebration while they're
taking this it's like the district
attorney's office that she wants the
conviction so she can move up and her
career can be good she'll give you 100
years
and he's looking for why why so much
like why you had to do that and it was
like what you did it
and her mind is is her doing her job and
her moving up to the next level and she
just knock you over because you become
collateral damage when things start to
spread
and they're aware that you you're active
or you're doing what you're doing
he called me too
so you know if you think
it's going to be a one-sided situation
you're wrong you just got to make sure
you go so hard the very first time that
there's not a time for me to come back
all we do is look at everybody have it
all day come through the feed it's crazy
yeah it kind of makes people feel like
there's not much because some people
look at it like you came to remind them
how much you have the other way is to
remind them how much they don't have so
they're angry with you for having it I
don't care what everyone thinks about me
if I did I would be a mess and you look
and you say you think I care about that
because when I can hold on to the
success that I've had and the things
that make me feel good if you haven't
had that success what do you hold on to
when I say it back to you like the
people come to you and they got anger
and it it's really coming from somewhere
else like that they're real rage is
putting your middle finger up back at
them because if you do they may be
already at the edge and they're gonna
crash and you just cause them to crash
into you when they would have crashed
into something else
you know yeah when I look at it like
that I go let me just control when I'm
aggressive about things and then when I
do do it it's calculated so now I mean
it when I'm doing it
when you look at cinematography itself
is our imitating life yeah and when you
see people uh
make choices that it could have been
choices instead of power but Power means
the same thing
in every language
I think money is rude to all evil but
look it'll make you do things the lack
of it but when you look up and you see
uh
people that have
uh what you review is uh Financial
Freedom from that perspective and that's
the route that they took
it feels like the way to go like it
doesn't have requirements and then for a
guy that when they're starting this in
in the youth they're starting this at
the age that they're not even
responsible for
their own behaviors yeah a lot of the
stuff that we see like the criminal
activities and gang culture
it'd be young guys that um
they haven't developed a concept what
you're thinking yeah yeah I don't think
they really know what what they're doing
like there's a lot of wet pillows in
prison yeah like under the circumstances
of being incarcerated while they're
alone yeah they're crying but they're
not
doing it in front of anybody they
already been bumped around enough
they're damaged the damage is Enough by
the experience that even if they make it
they won't make it if they don't figure
out how not to be who they are right now
they have to turn into something bigger
and better as they go with the new
information and New Opportunities new
things they come because they really
street they're really out there if I
could skip the hard parts that went
through I'll skip it
you know this is the things that your
parents saw that your people around you
would try to help you to avoid you know
telling you early now you don't want to
do that you know caught up to that and
then it's a lot of stuff this day like
I would avoid them now look look they
didn't even they're not a part of
it may be a product of the success
because it's part of my temperament
comes from it and the experience and how
I view things
but
it's not a part of the actual success
I'm being successful doing things that
are a lot different from what I was
doing at that point well you just go get
the information from to think outside of
that environment and see the you know
possibilities of different things that
you might want to do and actually be
able to find information to occupy
yourself with
with learning I learned so much about
myself over that time because
if you ask me to make a wish now I'm
just going to wish for more wishes
because I need to feel the confirmation
of success
repeatedly look at different points like
some people get hit the lick and go away